all right hello everyone welcome to
Android design in action this week's
episode is unlike the other episodes
that you've seen this week we're going
to have a hangout a google+ hangout on
air alright that's probably good idea i
would have a Google+ hangout on air to
discuss design specifically this show or
other you know top tips or anything that
folks may have I'm as always your host
Roman Nurik hey guys adam crush and Nick
butcher unfortunately couldn't join
today I think he's out sick we've
invited him to the Hangout just in case
he wants to join but he'll probably stay
home and and rest up for next week so
with that let's get started we're going
to structure the format of this hangout
I'm not like a regular hangout where we
just talk about stuff we're going to go
into a few slides in the very beginning
you want to talk briefly about the nexus
4 and Nexus 10 very very briefly and
then at the end we'll have a few slides
as well but for most of this episode
will be you know talking to the folks
that have joined to see what thoughts
they may have so let's jump into the
slides so um Android design in action
let's see if I can navigate this thing
there we go so the nexus 4nexus 10 as
many of you know these are the newest
devices Google these are the newest
devices in the Nexus family of products
the nexus 4 is a is a handset 4.7 inches
diagonal you can see all the screen
specs here the nexus 10 is a 10 inch
device so it's kind of a new reference
device if you will for for a 10 inch
size kind of replacing the motorola xoom
in our opinion for you know pure Android
kind of experiences the important thing
to notice that you know this is I guess
the first time madam that we've had a
such a such a high density tablet
display before you know almost all
tablet displays tender sub with space of
an mdpi I think any of them have been
anything other than in deeper yeah yeah
so these yeah they've all been roughly
I guess 1280 x 800 pixels and so this
doubles that so you now have a crazy
number of pixels on the screen the good
thing is that the dip resolution hasn't
changed so you know your existing
layouts will just work the the
difference though is that the assets
that will be using those layouts you
know if you have buttons and things like
that they'll be you know twice the
density so so basically 320 dpi answers
any assets I get shared from your phone
UI we should switch over certain notes
yeah gone hey good good boy um yeah n
eso share from your phone UI you know
obviously the the tablet your way on a
nexus 10 will just pick those up
immediately but if you have any assets
that are specific to tablet layouts you
will need to update to include xhdpi
yeah also for a nexus 4 it's worth
mentioning that the width is slightly
larger than Galaxy Nexus it's 1280 by
768 as opposed to 1280 by 720 yeah and
that maps to about 24 extra dips
horizontal dips of resolution for for
the nexus 4 as compared to the Galaxy
Nexus or other devices like that so
that's the new devices i mean there's
lots and lots of other stuff to talk
about but you know we you guys probably
know all these things from from all the
different press that's been out there
but these are kind of some of the some
of the details that are probably
important to designers and think about
these new devices and then just a recap
you know we now have the nexus for the
Nexus 7 and Nexus 10 and here again
they're they're rough screen specs at
you up the other thing we should point
out is that you know Launcher icons as
many of you know when designing for a
tablet for mdpi tablets i guess the
older density or the earlier density for
tablets when designing for mdpi tablets
you also want to provide an HTTP I
launcher icon because what the launcher
does and the launcher is that home
screen as many of you know what the
launcher does is when it displays an
icon for a nap it chooses the one bucket
larger icon because it wants a
physically larger icon so instead of
showing a 48 by 48 dip icon in the
launcher it
chooses to show a larger iconic launcher
so to get a an icon of of that high
resolution it basically uses a shortcut
it basically looks at the the asset was
the same asset at a higher density uses
that so on xhdpi tablets like the Nexus
10 that one bucket larger that one size
larger icon is actually xxhdpi or 480
dots per inch the the important thing to
note here is that the tablet itself the
screen itself is not xxhdpi it's simply
that the framework and the launcher will
be looking at xxhdpi it will be looking
for an icon in that folder so basically
you want to provide just the launcher
icon in 40 DPI and nothing else because
I mean everything else will just not be
used so xhdpi for all your regular
assets and then your launcher icon
should be in both xhdpi and xxhdpi and I
believe this only holds true for tablets
so nexus 7 included but not for headsets
yeah all right and I think that's really
all the slides we had um so let's jump
into let me just turn off the screen
share let's jump into the discussion so
um to get started I'd say we you know we
should all just introduce ourselves
really quickly um like I said I mean I'm
Roman we have Adam here um do you guys
want to just go a round table and
introduce yourselves maybe starting with
a keel okay hey guys i'm a 17 year old
android developer from ashburn virginia
um I I've only recently started I
finished learning java and like
extensively and I'm actually gonna apply
to the goop computer science institute
and the summer so hopefully I could see
you guys there um I use fireworks is my
program of choice for design and
obviously i like to use eclipse because
it's easy to work with for me Mumford
and it's okay that's introduction cool
okay you want to move on to Ed yeah hi
I'm it and I'm a designer working mostly
relieved that it is as well and I work
for a company called quite and yeah
we're working on them bringing the quite
up to ollie standards at the moon and so
a bit rude very cool all right um Linden
do you enjoy next g'day i'm linden
darling i'm a professional android
developer based in australia I make my
own apps also provide Android
development to you know banks and other
companies to make their ass I do a
little bit of doubling in in sort of
design and multimedia as well so cool
cool Linda Williams it in Australia I'm
in Melbourne okay I'm from Melbourne
originally and I'm hopefully met our
counterparts in Sydney Alison and
cocotte well yeah yeah yeah like some I
don't know why they based in Sydney to
be honest how about used to have a
mobile of this bird's got a cool all
right and a run is it Ron or ran its ran
Randy organics yeah I'm ran I'm an
Android developer from actually from
Israel so we're covering I think the
whole world and only missing unique from
from UK and then we have a Europe um
actually I'm a GD expert and I'm working
a lot here in the community and
providing professional services to
companies or building community events
talking in them and so awesome well
welcome to the hangout and we have two
other participants oscar and i believe
it's France DeAndre i'm not sure but if
you guys want to introduce yourselves
feel free although your video video is
muted if not then we'll just move on ok
and feel free to join at any point so
there's yeah is it DeAndre or is that my
pronounce that right I'm damn sure
Dondre you want to introduce yourself
sir I am a android developer started a
little over a year ago I'm in San
Francisco Hey yes I served at the
interesting point where you guys were
like switching to hollow to point out
and then like ice cream sandwich came
out and did like jelly bean so it's been
like pretty drastic change since what I
learning when I started and how it is
now yeah android has has gone under
somewhat of a reimagining I guess the
core visual visual image and basic
visual identity has really just gone
under a complete renovation since maybe
even two years ago so yeah that's a
great time to join welcome to welcome to
android and oscar we're assuming that
you're just kind of a bit shy or you
know don't want to join or have a video
muter such but anyway we'll just get
started feel free to join in when you're
ready um god I have to suck it working
here okay um so guys do you want to just
start off with like any sort of top tips
that you have or maybe even like you
know favorite apps or anything like that
the floor is really yours you know what
types of things do you want to talk
about um I was wondering you felt like I
could show like a design maybe oh yeah
sure totally and this is my chrome um
I'm working curtain I actually showed
Roman this I emailed him a while back
and it's basically a course organizing
app for students that I'm currently
working on and it lets students
basically organize all their courses and
assignments and schedules with your
teachers and their contacts with your
teachers um uh what I have one question
what if you can see my um a contextual
action bar here one color should I make
that Wow of all the questions so
conceptual action bars I mean
just using the default colors generally
fine in general like you just want you
really want to just hint it's a
different mode yeah so really you know
maybe a darker version if you do want to
change it then maybe you know a slightly
darker version of your of your core
accent color which seems to be kind of
brown I mean like the general palette is
kind of you know brown like an art like
a dark burnt orange and like a tan paper
so maybe something that's somewhere
along the spectrum may be slightly
darker but i think that the big big
important point here is that you just
want to visually indicate that it's a
different mode so as long as it's fairly
different from the standard action bar
it should be okay maybe else has
thoughts feel free to jump in yeah I was
just going to say I think it's fine to
leave it to be honest unless you really
want to get that full seeming across all
beat up um I think I think it's fine
yeah and in general I mean like when we
talk about hollow it's you know there's
there's lots of different guidelines
that that fold under hollow this hollow
umbrella you know one of those
guidelines is the visuals right but I
think for me the visuals are less
important and it's and what's more
important is the interactions right so
having the like the check box there
right having the done button there is
far more important than like the you
know the specific color of the action
bar like that is really up to you as a
designer to choose you know what looks
best to you but really the core things
that you should you know be leaving are
the standard kind of expected
interactions like pressing the top left
area which would be a checkbox to you
know to close the action mode having the
action overflow there in case there are
additional action so you know it's
really for me more about the interaction
side of things now then the visual side
of things although the visuals are
important it's really just up to you to
make them look it yeah and one more
question um if you were to like for the
check boxes here if you were to like if
someone was to click on it do you think
it's a good good for them to for the for
the entire list item to like go to the
bottom of the list or it's just a hot
day there the check box showing means
that it's kind of like a completed task
yeah um in general I'd say you know and
this is just a general rule you know do
what people would expect and in general
what users expect is what they're used
to what they're accustomed to and so if
there is something on the system
especially if it comes with their device
if there's a gas system app or platform
app that that does this exact thing then
just mirror what that does because
that's just what they're going to be
accustomed to in this case I can't think
of anything that like anything where a
check box mark something is completed
that's built into the system so in this
case I mean you don't really have much
of a default to rely on one thing you
could consider those you know when you
when you interact with something if it's
jumping around it's going to be hard to
continually interact with it so let's
say you wanted to you know check it you
know market is completed and then do
something else to it if you market is
checked and then it jumps down you know
your finger is no longer at the at the
relevant target right so you basically
have to jump around there that's that's
just another you know minor point i
think it's it's less important than
following conventions because again
that's just what people are going to
expect but i think in this case you know
having a jump around too much maybe a
negative thing all right comment on it
yeah i guess and he liked you if you do
printed evolve a list and the bottom of
the list is actually off the bottom of
the screen then you're probably gonna
struggle to find that moved item so
maybe and try and distinguish it a bit
more than just being checked i know a
lot of apps change to the color or maybe
some kind of strike through or something
it's at an item that's quite a common
plan yeah and one of the one of our
favorite apps the tasks ab by team tasks
they do exactly that they just show an
additional strikethrough as an
additional visual indicator that
something is checked actually i would go
over there with a swipe to dismiss
instead of the checkbox definitely
another option absolutely none option we
talked about this on not last week but
two weeks ago or three weeks ago on the
hunt that episode it's like to dismiss
is definitely other option Nick's very
much in favor that
yeah you can still get in a
task-management like any dude they're
doing it and I can think of her other
apps but it's very natural to the user
to just get things out of his way I'm
curious on how you would go about
implementing the swipe to dismiss
actually I mean this maybe I may be
going over way over my time so I'm
probably like done but actually that's
easy I think Roman it's it's your
library right yeah so um I don't have to
keep pressing around i got these
hangouts are very different so yeah i
wrote a library all nighter library gist
on github that basically did such
dismiss for you so for any list view or
any linearly a vertical linear layout it
gives you that swipe with automatically
but one of the differences that is like
the item that you swipe to dismiss
actually then goes away when some in
some cases in this case i don't really
know if you want the item to disappear
so much as you want to change its visual
state so you may be able to use some of
the things from that library you know in
this app but i don't think necessarily
that swiping to hide the item would
would work with yeah what one thing Nick
pointed out the other week was a really
nice pattern is to swipe and then have
an undo button kind of hiding underneath
and then you tap that it comes back
again um just nothing to think about
yeah alright I kill maybe you want to
show just one more screen then we'll
move on to other topics uh actually no I
was done with okay all right overall
yeah it was a great job and like like
you said I did see it before you sent me
that email is a great job overall
there's just some minor things but yeah
following that through and publishing it
on google play let us know when when
that happens and we'll we'll make sure
to take a look and and see if there's
any sort of you know promotion we can we
can provide but yeah it's a really great
start to the job there sir okay thanks
anyone else want to either show their
work or or talk about and also one of
the things one of the options if you
want to rant about something for like a
full minute bio me there's plenty to
rant about I'm sure but um if you do
want to rant about it that's that's just
another option but if you also if you
have if you
work to show if you get comments from
the rest of the folks here then let's
definitely option any takers hey yeah so
I got a couple things to show let's see
him can you hear me yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah cool okay so I'll be real quick
obviously there's the Android assets
viewer which I think everyone's going to
find very useful um another thing is a
little likely that I've been working on
basically sort of extends and faces up
on the set error functionality or
feature and Android app inside ok weekly
show you that it's a little validation
it's a cool name yeah yeah so it's
providing like easy validation performs
as well as making the feedback sort of
consistent so you know you've got cetera
working for any text textview derived
class arm of you but it doesn't work to
say it's so a spinner so I'm or a
selector so um basically you can add set
error you can extend up any view and
make it set error abul and then use this
validation manager and it'll it'll just
set the error on anything that's that's
got errors on it so um that's stemmed
from from me having to sort of provide
feedback in very complex sort of phones
in android apps I'll give it even like a
checkbox or like for example I you know
I accept the terms and conditions you
know if you don't accept if you don't
check it you can have a an error bubble
show a little bit i'm guessing right
yeah yeah so that's like a dependency
sort of um since the way out categorize
or named something like that so for
instance here if you you know you're
signing up to a newsletter you click
that yeah I want to sign up to the
newsletter
check box um that then makes the email
address fields necessary so if that
wasn't checked then you wouldn't be
getting an error turn on that one so
it's got a couple validators like you
know generally a lot of people will be
using the the regular expression
validator but you can write your own
once and our pinion as well oh yeah this
is open open source and afraid if you
guys could have a walk-in anyone that's
interested in using it or adding to it
or extending it gets involved sweet cool
and what was the Android assets viewer I
remember reading about it a little bit
but do you want to kind of give a brief
overview maybe show some examples yeah
let me just share that one tell me if
you can see it yep it's that it's that
up now you Dibble okay so kiss some
again asset stem from I suppose pains
that I've found in different contracts
working you know quickly to make apps
and working with designers that
generally new to android so basically
the idea is if you want to provide an
easy way to show graphics and look at
all of the graphics across your
different sized buckets on all the
drawable variants so this does that and
gives a little bit of analysis feedback
you know showing you whether your sizes
arrive whether you know whether you've
got like odd pixels or you know whether
you're going to have like half pixels
and stuff so for instance is the assets
I've uploaded the assets from formidable
validation that even that library I just
showed you um and you can see them here
that it's like showing your different
sizes so you've got your LD api's your
MVP is there's even the XX hdpi and
there just to be super fresh and here
you know it's missing an X
hdpi but it's saying that basically if
you were to put that into the right size
of it it's shown in green 96 x 96 so
these bitch p is providing this is just
look at which wich assets you currently
have so if you have like some random
assets that's like 40 by 40 in mdpi it
will show you what the equivalent is an
xhdpi and like an empty slot if it's not
there yeah yeah that's exactly what it's
doing here right so it's all all of
these based off mdpi at the moment i
might add something to sort of look at
sizing based on other other pockets if
the MV API isn't down mom but you can
see here that you know the MVP is 48 by
48 it's suggesting that the xhdpi well
as saying that it's not there and it
should be 96 x 96 you can see here that
TV DPI is always going to have it salsa
and a half pixels um and and so it's
it's I guess a way of you know when
you're talking to designers that are
trying to give you I us graphics and
don't want to do any more work this is a
great way to sort of bring them on board
and show them things no matter what does
that I'm sorry how do you how do you
actually put your assets into into this
oh yeah so you just upload either an apk
or um or a zip file if you're if you're
afraid that I'm going to
reverse-engineer your apk so I can do
anyway just getting it off the market
you can just zip your ear res folder and
and upload that so it's looking for a
red folder that's containing drawable
oldest so you got your drawer a really
adorable LBP I know deep guys look
whatever might have you a yield extra
large whatever bucket is there it's
going to show them all awesome I'll in
the move our own little low on time but
what's the last quick
yeah one last thing the device viewer so
this is something i added just recently
and it lets you basically do this stuff
on real devices scale as though it's um
you know on that device so i get get
gives you a real quick glimpse as to how
things are going to scale and and how
those graphics and the different buckets
are going to work on on different
devices out there you know original
smaller side so in this case it's a nine
patch you would scale and be bigger but
you can get it just for you know what I
would look like at its smallest size and
the most important thing women how do
you get to this awesome tool yeah sorry
the it's a sellable mmm which is how I
like cerebellum if you hold your tongue
and say it um / android assets viewers
so i'll just show you there again you
can push the week up in the in the
google play yeah what if we post the
link afterwards oh yeah okay let's let's
move on though since we're running a
little low on time I just want to get
one last thing from everybody who wants
to answer what would you like to see in
a future episode of Android design in
action what like specific topics would
you like us to cover and I let's start
it I guess from akhil crew John versus
toasts croutons versus Wars okay any
library I just want you want to bring if
who's out there like using crouton right
now okay yeah it's an awesome library
it's a it's definitely interesting to
spread a different and more it's more
contextual toast unless definitely a
good topic will keep that in mind um
D'Andre any thoughts oh I'll fast for
well today okay all right um ed or
Linden or yeah
a couple of requests and I guess one of
them is them is the production process
from graphics to to developer and how
you manage that process like DD designer
end DPI and then just email over a load
of graphics or you know do you share
some kind of Rico not just just our
production process be quite quite good
and I guess a little bit on fonts and
and thoughts on including more than just
the bold and regular and you know
whether that's a good idea it's do or
not and tablet apps like a lot of
developers have got and mobile apps out
there which could work on from up in
Nexus 7 and how much effort should be
put in to releasing for a tablet and
versus making people wait for the app
and releasing your custom tub that
totally and I mean we did have an
episode recently on responsive design
but we're definitely going to do even
more on tablet design since it is kind
of a it's a nuanced you know area in
designing for mobile since it's like
kind of semi mobile but definitely
definitely something that we're going to
continue to talk about and those other
points so there's other suggestions
we're great or definitely not look into
that as well linden and iran any any
thoughts on things we should cover from
future yeah um yeah i mean the stuff
that arm Nick and Marie did at some
conference in Germany I rice or a video
for that where they get a redesign on
the fly and show how the thoughts that
were gonna hire and it was really useful
and interesting I think that something
like that could be good to to do again I
think you do it with obviously lots of
different apps you guys sort of doing
that with your with you look at apps at
the minor in as well but I think having
a you know having the design tools out
there and showing how people enjoy it
quickly as well and also tackling like
that the big problem of you know making
making an appt look good on on sir
um honeycomb plus but as well as old you
know gingerbread 2.2 without say using
just going for a pure holo theme and
trying to pull that all back like you
know this is the limiting problem I know
you guys are trying to sort of pushing
for like that the newest style all the
time but the reality is that um you know
apps out there and it companies want to
get target as much much as they can and
stuff just doesn't look that great not
everything even hollow everywhere
doesn't bring everything back and so
yeah if there's any tricks or even
talking about some of the issues there
yeah so like maybe positionally an
episode dedicated out like backward
compatibility and designing for earlier
devices that makes a lot of sense since
that is a very kind of pragmatic view of
the current landscape as you know most
devices are below Android three-point oh
so definitely we should look at okay and
Randy have any thoughts on what we
should include thoughts and and they
request actually I started working on a
project it will be basically a car
mounted tablet that will replace the
entertainment system and we'll also talk
with the with some chip inside a vehicle
that talks with other vehicles other
cars to provide collaborative safety I
don't know if you guys have heard of and
that standards called 11 p but nevermind
we're not gonna know the idea is that it
is it's a 7-inch tablet that is gonna be
used applications going to be used
delicately in a car needs to be operated
by a driver or some or the passenger but
also by the driver so needs to be very
little interaction with the user and
obviously action bar cannot fit there
it's too small things like that so right
now we're banging our head against the
wall trying to figure out what will be
the best way your approach to show a map
some very necessary and valuable
information and that's it and still we
very responsive and intuitive to the
user if he wants to go to other screens
and you've got an amazing job with the
design guide but it's all focused for
mobile phones and mobile usage and that
stuff and there's actually Android is
going to other areas and not just
handsets tablets but also all right
basically so basically exploring how to
design for kind of a alternative or
auxiliary use cases like so that's
outside of the standard kind of holding
a phone in your hand while holding a
tablet in your two hands yeah definitely
definitely we can look at we'd probably
need to see if you example devices right
a few example use cases but definitely
we can kind of imagine what is the the
next step you know designing for the the
next step or the evolution of Android
devices in different areas different use
case and there are some apps that need
to do something like that anyway like
navigation apps for example that or yeah
sort of you know cater to that use case
totally ok so we're we're a super low on
time but we just want to run through a
few last slides I'm here a little bit
more information or share um to bear
with us for just a second so um let's
just quickly run through news and there
isn't too much news I'll actually the
most important bit of news here is that
a UI stencils com has just recently
released a android tablet stencil kit
and this is like a physical metal piece
of kit I guess that you that you you
know plop down on some paper you know
you fill in the blanks and you get you
know your standard iconography you get
your standard widgets things like that
so if you're looking to kind of sketch
on real paper with real pens and pencils
then try to get this kit we actually do
have an example here and you're not
going to be able to see it i'll show it
after but the really cool thing is that
we have a few to give away so we're
going to be giving away about ten and so
i guess about ten of these so the way
in which we're going to do this is that
we're going to ask the greater community
to take a few screens from one of their
favorite apps or even their own app
redesign it you know using some of the
hollow elements that you've seen on this
show and then post it to Google+
publicly by the end of the week and when
you do post make sure to use the
hashtags a dia and Android design so we
can see them and then so the first or
maybe the best ten we don't really know
yet we'll try to send out some of these
stencils these stencils I think they
retail for 27 bucks on on you I stencils
com so if you want to just get them not
wait for us to you know to look at your
stuff then just go to you I stencils
calm and get your copy and we'll post
details about the about this giveaway at
some point on Google+ as well probably
right after the show also I did two
posts very recently first on wizard
design like designing a wizard in this
case one that lets you order a sandwich
very very oddly enough but it's got all
sorts of things like dependencies like
dependent sections and things like that
so if you're designing wizards check out
that post and lastly a cheat sheets as
another post I did basically in the
action bar is many of you know when you
long press an icon in the action bar it
shows you a little toast a little tool
tip that pops up and says what that does
this is really useful outside of just
the action bar so if throughout your UI
you have icon only UI elements you'll
want to use something like this to give
the user an extra bit of confidence that
what they're about to press does what
they think so this is especially
important in cases where your
iconography may may not make perfect
sense so there's a library I guess
another github gist that shows you how
you could do this and that's at this
post here so I think that's all the
slides we have I think that's all the
slides we have today um thanks again for
joining guys we're hoping to do a few
more of these hangouts in the future for
the next few weeks we'll probably go
back to our regularly scheduled Android
design in action will will where we will
be doing redesigns so
yeah but look at look for other
invitations to join another hangout
sometime in the next say few weeks or
next two months so thanks for joining
everybody and um you know I guess we'll
see you next week it's going to I don't
I yeah